got a great little mathematical
induction proof question here it's an
inequality which seems to be what most
people struggle with and we have to
prove that to the N is greater than or
equal to N squared for this domain the
positive integers starting from four so
four five six seven eight and so on okay
so how do we go about proving this and
why is it difficult well before I
actually start on the proof itself I'm
going to give a bit of an explanation of
how I'm going to go about the proof now
there's a couple of different ways like
approach this okay the first way is to
start at the most natural place you know
let's let's call that step one right and
then as you go along and progress in
step one you run up against the problem
okay and when you get to that problem
you think oh okay something's gone wrong
I need to do some other stuff I need to
do some other step I'm in order to fix
up what's gone wrong in step one and
then once you do that other step you
bring that back so you return to step
one you continue it and then after that
you finish and you do your last thing
your conclusion okay so you go step one
you sort of realize you've got a problem
do this second step bring it back to the
first step and then you finish okay now
this way is fine this way will work but
it's a little awkward isn't it that you
sort of starting one way and then you've
got to stop it and pick it up again
later now how would you do it otherwise
to make it a little more sort of logical
or sort of neater I suppose well this
result here this step if you're going to
need it for to prove this step you could
start off with that step once you
establish that then you can start off
step one and you don't need to go do
some sideways theme because when you run
into the problem it won't be a problem
anymore because you can use this earlier
result that you proved and then you can
finish right now you can see both of
these approaches have problems okay this
approach has the problem of being sort
of you know you have to break your logic
do some side thing and then return to it
the problem with this is when you when
you have a look at this you think why
are you even starting here it's not the
most natural place to start it's not
obvious that this would be the most
logical place
well then you would need this and your
next step so you know they both got
their issues to make this proof a little
neater and go a little faster I'm going
to go this way and I try and point out
the the problem that would have come up
if we'd done it you know normally and
going from step one okay so hopefully
that'll make sense of why I'm about to
start where I do so I want to prove this
inequality rather than prove that off
the bat I want to consider a different
one I want to consider or I want to try
and prove the ^ n is not greater than or
equal to N squared but that it's greater
than or equal to 2n plus 1 for the same
domain
okay now turns out this is quite a lot
easier to prove than the original one
but we're going to need this result this
inequality to prove the whole thing so
let's start off okay now how do I I'm
going to do this by mathematical
induction has a normal proof by
mathematical induction begin where we
have to test the first allowable values
so I'm going to do that the first law
will value being N equals four okay so
on the left hand side what have I got
that's to the power 4 which is 16 on the
right hand side I've got 2 times 4 plus
1 which is 8 plus 1 which is 9 so sure
enough the left hand side is greater
than or equal to the right hand side by
quite a margin
therefore it's true for that value okay
now what comes next in the proof well we
need our assumption so this is the the
mathematical sort of inductive step if
you like so I'm going to assume the
statement is true for some our true
values that I like and I'll call that K
where K follows the same rules that n is
supposed to follow so it's an integer
starts from before okay it's got to be
most more than 4 okay so what does that
look like I'll just swap out all my ends
for K so it's going to look like this so
this is what I'm going to assume is true
and now what I'm required to prove off
the back of that is that it's true for
the next value along
that's how all mathematical induction
proofs work okay so what does that look
like it looks like this to the k plus 1
is greater than now this will be 2 times
k plus 1 so that's 2 k plus 2 plus 1 so
that's 2 k plus 3 once you collect your
like terms all right so this is what I'm
trying to prove now how I go about doing
this this is pretty straightforward but
I go through it anyway let's just
consider what happens if I gather
everything on one side of this
inequality often that's easier because
if I gather the 2 k plus 3 on the other
side what I'm going to try and do is
prove that that's positive and proving
that something is positive is one of the
easier things to do okay so I'm going to
consider 2 k plus 1 minus 2 k plus 3
okay so we can do a bit of expansion
here what's that equal to that's 2 x to
the power of K minus 2 K minus 3 ok now
watch what happens this step is really
really important okay in order to use
the assumption that I've got over here
this assumption here okay
I'm going to notice that I've got a 2 to
the K here and I know that 2 to the K is
bigger than 2 k plus 1 ok so if I were
to swap that to 2 to the power of K out
swap it with 2 k plus 1 minus 2 K minus
3
ok now look at this with me I just
swapped that to the K with a 2 k plus 1
right and 2 to the K is greater than or
equal to at least 2 k plus 1 so out of
these two lines this one in this one
which one would be bigger hmm which one
bigger than the other and the answer is
well if you have a look at just this
part right this part here should be
bigger than this part here yeah so
therefore as a whole this whole line
ought to be bigger than this whole line
right so therefore I can say that and
don't forget that this line is actually
equal to this so 2 k plus 1 minus 2 k
plus 3 that should be greater than or
equal to this line with the
yum with the the swaps so this I'm
actually using the assumption here so by
assumption okay
so just watch out for this this is this
is a tricky part people get confused
going from here to here right I've got
an equality that implies an inequality
when I bring in the assumption okay
alright so I've got that being greater
than that so I can progress now on this
right-hand side now that I've done my
substitution some of this stuff can um
can be expanded and simplified out so
I've got 4 K plus 2 minus 2 K minus 3
put that up here and get rid of this
piece of paper that okay now what if I
got what I got next I've got well if I
got 4 K minus 2 K that'd be 2 K 2 minus
3 that's minus 1 so now I've got this
this is what I had on the left hand side
I've got that being greater than or
equal to 2 K minus 1 okay
but don't forget that K is not just any
number right it's got to be greater than
or equal to 4 that was the UM that was
the the domain for K right so therefore
I can say that what's here on the left
hand side I can do another swap right if
I swapped K 4 4 so up K 4 4 which is
becoming going to become 8 this one
right which line will be bigger will
this be bigger or will this be bigger
they could be the same size if K was
exactly equal to 4 but for all other
values 5 6 7 8 9 10 and so on this will
be bigger than this right so this line
again is bigger than that okay right I'm
almost there so I've got this being true
that it's greater than or equal to 7 and
7 is a positive number right it's it
itself is greater than or equal to 0
right so now I've proved that this thing
we had on the left hand side that's
greater than or equal to 0 so now I can
route over this to K + 3 and put it on
the other
side this is what I got okay so now that
means what does that mean the statement
is true for N equals K plus 1 that's
that's what I was trying to prove here
right how do I prove that it's true for
N equals k plus 1 that's what it's look
like that's what it looks like and
that's that's what I've got here ok
excellent so now I can conclude that you
know by the principle of mathematical
induction and by the way some people
accept this as a sort of abbreviation
and they don't have to write extra stuff
and some people don't so just check with
your teacher whoever your arm whoever's
going to mark your stuff but this is
this is fine by the principle of
mathematical induction I can go back to
my original statement which is this 1 2
to the N is greater than or equal to 2n
plus 1 and I can say that that's true
for all of the values that I've proved
it for Emily groaning equal to 4 okay
excellent
now I've just proved this result so what
um it hasn't actually proved for me what
I'm after namely this original question
2 to the N it's not greater than this
guy but N squared ok so now that I've
proved this result this result okay I'm
going to store that away and I'll keep
that in my head and now I'm going to
tackle the the original question in
earnest okay so let's let's get a new
color here all right now since this is a
whole new proof in some ways I'm going
to start it like I normally would which
is to test the first allowable value
okay so what does that look like I'm
trying to prove a 2 to the N is greater
than or equal to N squared so the left
hand side is 2 to the N which is 2 to
the 4 which is again 16 what's the right
hand side it's N squared so that's 4
square which is also 16 that's okay
because I've got an equality on this
boundary so in this case the left-hand
side is still greater than or equal to
the right hand side so it's true for N
equals 4
okay that was my test now I'm going to
assume the statements true for an
arbitrary value which I'm going to call
K which again follows the same rules
that we've been talking about greater
than or equal to four and what does that
look like what it should be
let's see here was I trying to prove su
to the okay if he was on the right hand
side and greater than or equal to K
squared okay now that I've assumed that
what I want to try and prove is for the
next value along k plus 1 so what does
that look like 2 to the k plus 1 greater
than equal to k plus 1 or square okay
now in order to prove this I'm going to
pull exactly the same kind of trick that
I did before which is to consider what
happens if I bring everything over to
one side ok so if I say let's just have
a think about this to the k plus 1 minus
k plus 1 all squared now you can see if
I can prove that this is greater than or
equal to 0 then I'm done I can go home
because once I've got that greater than
equal to 0 I can move the K plus 1
squared over the other side and that's
what I'm trying to prove okay so how do
I go about doing that well I can do a
little bit of um simplifying here write
that 2 to the k plus 1 means 2 to the K
times 2 to the 1 right so it's 2 times
okay okay and what's this this I can
expand this this is K squared plus 2 k
plus 1 ok now what can I do that I to
work with this well the first thing I
want to notice is that my assumption
what I proved what I'm assuming here has
to do with 2 to the K okay and I have
the 2 to the K here I actually have two
of them okay now for reasons that I hope
will become clear in a second I'm going
to separate them out I'm going to put 2
to the K here and I'm not a turd okay
there we've got this guy you
okay now just like before I'm going to
swap one of these out for a K squared
okay so let's leave that to the K at the
front the same and I'm going to turn
this two to the K into a K squared okay
now remembering remembering that I've
assumed two to the K is bigger than K
squared between these two lines which
one will be bigger
well this to the K should be giving in K
squared everything else is the same
right so this line ought to be greater
than or equal to this next line that
I've written right and don't forget this
is actually equal to this okay so this
is by assumption I've just used the the
inductive hypothesis here by assumption
okay sorry that's a bit I need more
space by assumption this is true because
I've done this swap okay all right well
you can see where's is going this case
where in this case clay will cancel so I
get to the K minus after I cancel these
two guys I'm left with 2 k plus 1 okay
now aha you can see why I did this
result before because at this point if
we had started proving this right you
know a test the first lower value and
see where it goes
you'd run up to here and then you think
oh how do I prove that this is positive
okay and then you'd have to go off
elsewhere and do do what we did before
and improve all of this stuff that is
positive okay but I I've rather that
this part is greater than that part so
now that I've already proved that I can
say we're on a second to the K is going
to be greater than or equal to 2 k plus
1 that's what I went and proved in my in
the first stage of my proof okay so
therefore if this number is bigger than
this number the whole thing ought to be
greater than 0 it should be it should be
positive right if you've got a big
number minus a small number you're going
to get a positive number left over so
it's got to be greater than or equal to
zero the only way that it would not be
is if this number were smaller than this
number okay so now I'm almost there
I've had this on the left hand side
right so now all I need to do is kick
this guy back over to the right-hand
side of the inequality and I get this
it's greater than equal to K plus 1 or
squared which is what I was trying to
prove right
so the statement is true for N equals k
plus 1 assuming you can assume that it's
that it's true for N equals K right so
that's it I'm done now by the principle
of mathematical reduction including both
of those parts of the proof that I used
I can say now that 2 to the N is greater
than or equal to N squared for those
given values
sorry that's a 5 those given values of M
we're finished